[Applaudissements]
200 da quelle est la première chose
eric d'anvers et eric les chauffeurs de
salle il a tu faisais pas compris qu'on
n'était pas dans le coup donc il fait
tout ça pour dire le public ça fait
trois semaines qu'on a repris les
missions ces trois jeunes
il a toujours pas compris ça c'est le
premier truc ça c'est pas grave problème
quand même bravo eric deuxième chose je
serais content de vous voir et j'ai pris
une grande décision comme emmanuel
macron par exemple le conseil des
ministres il paraît qu'il fait l'appel
et ben moi aussi je vais faire l'appel
pour voir castaldi présent kiko en
plateau merci bouge toi le cul non toi
que tu attends tu as toi ainsi tout pas
là merci françois viot présent présent
en plateau
merci sans rien dire à un inspecteur des
impôts les appels morini-bosc gelé vue
oui si vous faites là tu veux moi kelly
et là c'est bon car hier je les ai vus
naulleau c'est beau mallet ces bons
présente a gâté les l'agate agathe
oui ça marche et le truc dingue tu as
changé de lunettes agathe c'est en ces
mots du pôle emploi tout je trouve qu'un
gâteau elle est homogène et ça effraie
sa mère maya ims est bon pour l exercice
et banque tous mourir à gâter
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est pas un problème
gilles courteau
du côté bohème grèce moi de chanter
que faire
tomba
[Musique]
oh
super héros au sens jamais prêt ou
serait ce à des prix
mais pourquoi je sais pas non ça jamais
pris ça j'avais pitié des mers et toi
mais là toi il est vrai - t'as vu ta
gueule c'est normal ça départ toit par
toi ça c'est sa série qu'il a tout fait
pas compris comme ça qu'on est tous qui
s'y colle et messieurs n'avait pas
démarré voilà donc le shérif même si on
quand on y donne aujourd'hui programme
de ouf
ces 23 septembre c'est mon anniversaire
j'ai vu des bus dévolu au calme au toit
ne peut pas tout avoir tout le temps aux
gonaïves
on va tout d'abord retient mercy bay n'a
alors aujourd'hui je vous le dit
programme de ouf
il y aura là tout de suite en début
d'émission les boiboite ya mieux que ça
ils sont vous le jure que ça c'est pas
qu'on le fera pas je vous le dis il ya
vraiment et c'est pas une vanne un
séjour et je vous le jure qu'on mette
fin à ce que si si si ou pas et on va
partir genre semaine prochaine à ses
jours avec moi et le chroniqueur qui
gagnera plus et plus vous gagnerez et
téléspectateurs le gagnerons sur twitter
hashtag tout de suite et pmp boiboite
donc voila vous partirez en week-end
avec montée des remparts à trois ans des
détecteurs bas le téléspectateur et sa
conjointe à 4 ou juin exactement par à 4
voilà alors attention et et ça ça va
être énorme et syrie et sinon
votre frère votre frère vous allez
quitter ces villes hadji qui tous et il
va être champion du monde c'est mon
frère aussi
[Applaudissements]
c'est le goût des fans le 12 août au 12
octobre
eva l'équipe n'a pas livré manoeuvre
dans les 1 servant à lui fallut
compagnie mais débrouille pour moi est
ce que tu penses qu'ils pourraient faire
un bon combattant lui ouais franchement
je regarde souvent et c'est que ça met
du tigre il a dit tu es bon hacker
bouffon et dany contre moi n'agissez pas
après ça chez moi sans que celui là il a
beaucoup plus d'envié de devenir roi tu
sais que je t'aime tant il saura
peut-être de ma mère à caen et tu me
steyer toi il ya un mois
[ __ ] j'adore va être champion du monde
il est exceptionnel c'est contraire aux
sanctions on va se faire plus qu'un
merci donc jours après l'émission
persuadé c'est parti ils sont
magnifiques mais chérie je suis très
très content parce qu'eric a compris
qu'il fallait pas faire un peu dire le
public ça déjà ça dès l'aube ou trois
semaines ça va
les chéris hier encore d'audois pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
besson
son breton
phénoménal
voilà
là
c'est toi qui s'y colle
bravo
[Applaudissements]
on a pas record oui oui je pense que
c'est grâce à vous parce que c'était
votre anniversaire hier j'avais oublié
de vous offrir un modèle je suis très
déçu c'était un bémol elle savait mère
de famille
[Musique]
chez moi les postes
ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans l'équipe
m
[Musique]
et puis ce sera non tu vois pas qu'on
sera jamais prêt mais je suis désolé et
question venez là la musique se taire et
spatial aient pris cui a way back bombe
alors allez y aura alors tous au pôle
emploi et maa sera jamais prêt jamais et
pourquoi pourquoi je sais pas pourquoi
vous sera jamais prêt bordel c'est la
merde on fait de la merde t'es dur avec
nous non cela s'est fait ailleurs je
suis arrivé là